[Música]
actualización de las noticias económicas
con Juan Pablo lukumi un saludo
nuevamente Juan Pablo Hola que estamos
nuevamente y nos trae un tema de la
región la Unión Europea apoyará
proyectos sostenibles colombianos con
alrededor de dos millones de dólares Así
es Ángela la inversión será para cinco
proyectos destinados a estimular la
transición energética y mejorar la
competitividad de pequeñas y medianas
empresas se espera que la inversión
beneficia más de 2.500 emprendedores y
mipymes colombianas Se esperan proyectos
de la asociación Nacional de comercio
exterior de la Unión Europea y pues
también que trabajará para que 400
unidades productivas agropecuarias del
sector de las frutas y las hortalizas
adopten prácticas innovadoras y
sostenibles y también puedan incrementar
sus exportaciones fuera del país Bogotá
la capital recibirá casi 500 mil dólares
de esos dos millones de dólares que se
invertirá de la Unión Europea
tenemos más temas económicos pero vamos
a concentrarnos bastante en Estados
Unidos porque como hemos venido haciendo
el seguimiento durante esta semana y
como esperaban los mercados El Banco
Central estadounidense elevó nuevamente
los tipos de interés Ángela vamos a
hablar de Estados Unidos hemos
concentrado que hablar de Europa en un
tiempo luego de América Latina y de Asia
hoy el tema es Norteamérica el aumento
fue de 25 puntos básicos y ahora el
precio del dinero queda entre el 4,5% y
el 4,75% se trata del octavo ascenso
consecutivo desde que inició el
endurecimiento de la política monetaria
para frenar la inflación el movimiento
de hoy es una reducción del ritmo de
aumentos de los tipos antes Un aumento
de medio punto y otros cuatro de 75
puntos básicos el presidente de la
reserva Federal de Estados Unidos
anticipó que el Banco Central llevará a
cabo Durante los próximos meses más
aumentos de los tipos de interés el
mercado Espera que sean menos agresivos
El Banco Central la economía más grande
del mundo busca reducir la inflación al
2% Desde que la inflación alcanzó su
máximo en junio de 9,1% ha caído hasta
el 6,5% anual en diciembre bajo por
sexto mes consecutivo entonces un dato
que según los analistas es señal de que
la subida de los tipos están comenzando
a hacerle frente a la economía
estadounidense escuchemos a jeremond el
presidente de la fete
la inflación se mantiene muy por encima
de Nuestro objetivo a largo plazo del 2%
Durante los 12 meses que finalizaron en
diciembre los precios subieron un 5% y
excluyendo las volátiles categorías de
alimentos y energía los precios de la
inflación subyacente subieron un
4,4%, los datos de inflación recibidos
en los últimos tres meses muestran una
reducción del Ritmo mensual de aumentos
Y aunque la evolución reciente es
alentadora necesitaremos muchas más
evidencias Para estar seguros de que la
inflación se encuentra en una Senda
descendente sostenida
también se conocieron Juan Pablo hace
pocos minutos en las decisiones del
banco de Inglaterra y del Banco Central
europeo Cuál fue la decisión de los
emisores Ángela noticias que estábamos
esperando precisamente lo decíamos al
inicio de los noticieros y tanto el
Banco Central europeo como el banco de
Inglaterra decidieron también subir las
tasas de interés en 50 puntos básicos
con esto el precio del dinero queda
entre el 4% para Reino Unido y un 3%
para el bloque europeo Esta es la décima
vez consecutiva que el emisor británico
eleva los tipos y la quinta subida
consecutiva del Banco Central europeo
Pese a que la inflación se diera en el
último trimestre 2022 con esto ya
tenemos todos los datos que esperábamos
para hoy a ver ayer también anticipamos
que se iban a reunir el presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden y el presidente
de la cámara de representantes Kevin
mccarthy tema muy importante los reunía
y era hablar sobre el techo de la deuda
un tema que también seguro hablaremos
para varios meses de pronto hasta junio
estaremos hablando de este tema aunque
no hay acuerdos todavía si hubo una
buena discusión entre ambos lo que
presenta como algo positivo por el
momento ambas partes acordaron continuar
con la conversación el problema recae en
que los republicanos con Kevin mccartría
la cabeza amenazan con bloquear el
aumento del límite de crédito del país
esto si los demócratas no aceptan
recortes presupuestarios drásticos para
sus gastos en el futuro los republicanos
ostentan el control de la cámara de
representantes de Estados Unidos desde
que ganaron esa mayoría en las
elecciones de noviembre las palabras de
Game mccarthy dieron algo de calma a
esta situación escuchemos
creo que sí podemos llegar a un acuerdo
sobre el techo de la deuda y que
podríamos tener un acuerdo de
financiación para los próximos dos años
no estoy en una posición para señalar
con el dedo estoy para hacer el
presidente de la cámara mi papel en este
momento es asegurarme de que tengamos
una capacidad sensata y responsable para
aumentar la deuda pero no continuar con
este gasto desbocado
indicadores para esta jornada Juan Pablo
revisemos entonces las bolsas asiáticas
porque cer mixtas luego de los de que
estaban optimistas Porque algunos
inversionistas Pues acertaron el aumento
de las tasas de interés de Estados
Unidos y tras el anuncio de que Hong
Kong pues haría una multimillonaria
inversión para el sector del turismo en
Europa las bolsas siguen operando la
mayoría reportando ganancias Juan Pablo
gracias a usted y nos vamos sin demora
para directores nos vamos para París
[Música]